all right this was be a site for just
weary eyes of the skies of Baltimore and
soon Washington DC later today Atlanta
Georgia we're seeing the Blue Angels and
the Thunderbirds strut their stuff and
this is just so stunning to me how
majestic and impeccably a perfectly
timed it is I don't know how the heck
they do it but I know my next guest does
Lieutenant Colonel Kevin de falco
the Thunderbirds Director of Operations
a pilot himself so you do not mess with
the colonel colonel very good to have
you thank you very much for joining us
thank you for inviting you on the show
it's a wonderful idea and it comes at a
time when so many in the nation needed
they can look up and just be awestruck I
know I am but this has got to take a lot
of practice right to get it so right
down to the second down to the inches
huh yeah that's correct
it's so common performance numbers
throughout the country to be out and
about in the community and we often get
told thank you for our service and now
it's our turn our turn to recognize
those frontline workers and on behalf of
over 1 million servicemembers extend our
gratitude and say thank you for your
service to those frontline workers and
what you're seeing is a combination of
12 extremely qualified and experienced
combat veteran fighter pilots in close
formation in two different formations
that are providing us our story from the
skies you know what's amazing to me Carl
what I watch it it's how so synchronized
this is it can't afford not to be but
especially when you see it from a
cockpit as we are now
these guys are inches apart how the heck
do you do that well you know that takes
extensive training as I said extremely
experienced and qualified fighter pilots
meet we practice quite a bit and this is
really our best way to pass our message
of unity and strength and just bringing
the whole country together we want to
support everybody
their backs reply precisely together we
fly as one and bringing the airforce and
maybe there's really such opportunity
for us to pass that message elusiveness
[Music]
you know each claims rights to having
the better flying squad the Air Force
and the Navy they both seem pretty
stunning to me and they have to
coordinate this with each other so how
do they do this ahead of time and
practice at it Simon where the heck do
they do it so we even got a place to :
Florida with the Navy Blue Angels
opportunity to practice of eBay's to
make sure that we get this right and
look at very precise and perfect over
top these communities that are surveyed
show them that we can work together and
you have your facts and it is really our
message of unity with supreme air force
and maybe to TV you may think I have a
little bit of firmly competition
everybody knows it every day those
frontline workers they're working hard
working hard as well to make sure that
they know that we're ready we know that
they're ready as well at all times and
we support them just amazing currently
you're no slouch yourself in the intro
to Bartman but when heroes recognize
heroes it takes on added significance
Colonel thank you again not only what
you do but the message you're sending
today to those health care workers in
those frontline responders thank you
again sir